my talk is about electric cars
i need 1 new car
how appropriate
and I thought so
then electric
but it's hard not to get cynical about that
energy transition
those with electric cars
but as wopke Hoekstra 1 mega transition
can make dirty royal
shell boy to european ecoridder
well then i can also plug
everyone needs the electric car
but there is 1 small problem
completely electric
actually I think it's way too expensive
and I also think hybrid
even used cars at marketplace
its really screaming expensive I think
is expensive very expensive
1 little electric car comes to 40 €50,000 D66
or rob jetten I sometimes confuse them
had 1 plan also to the pepse the weathered filling
to help electrically
but for hulley then 1 / 2 or third hansje
but even those with 1 rotten battery
are still excessively expensive
yes but there was still a subsidy
yes only nice if you earn 3 times the average
less use is made of the subsidy pot
for electric cars
according to research of news hour
despite the government regulation
the purchase of plug-in cars remains for many people
too expensive even with almost €3,000 subsidy
it is still unreachable for most
this week it was announced that the insufficient subsidy
nevertheless remains intact
because private individuals cut off 1 bit in terms of electric
Europe can be the EU
do something about the prices of electric cars now
they can,
but they don't
because there too the climate appears
just a little less important than the economy
because there are enough cheap electric cars
but yes they come from China
the European Commission may want its own
protect car industry
at the expense of China
that according to the European Commission with subsidies
would bring electric cars to the European market
for 1 much too low price
or like euro
upper head boss Ursula von der leyen be it
global markets anal fluttered
with chiper chinese electric cars
very nice that cheap electric candle from China
but hop fat import tax on it
yes green deal and the climate
very nice
but first we will protect our own store
and yes then be
not alone
environmental considerations of importance
but certainly also economic considerations
it also remains difficult in my head
that the power for the electric car
still for sure
three-quarters is generated with the hated
fossil fuels
Anyway you have to start somewhere
oh yes that power from charging stations
everything goes wrong there
the price for example
you can usually use 1 charging station
not see what the electricity costs
and in our fantastic
liberal market
the energy suppliers make full abuse of this
yesterday I played radar or checkout
1kW of electricity cost with fat
and a lot instead of De Plaats Diemen €1 60
I have 1 screenshot and in Gouda I HAVE 1 screenshot
the same kilowatje 35cent
just compare
that would be the same as 1l gasoline
would cost €2 at 1 gas station
and at 1 other gas station €9 14
should not supervise that 1 bit
I SAY service path on wopke
and then there is something else
this outgoing cabinet creates even more financial
uncertainty about electric driving
that does not help if
there are uncertainties
are about for example the motorrijtuigenbelasting
in the future
electric cars are heavy due to the batteries
and motorrijtuigenbelasting
is determined by the weight
from 1 car now they are still exempt from tax
but how much do you have to pay in 3 years
of the outgoing centers
and from 2026 the full pound
and that is possible due to the heavy battery packs
walk well in the papers
strange that private individuals are wary
and you were allowed despite it
money doesn't matter dude
it's better for the environment
yes for the environment here
because for making 1 battery
Do you need cobalt,
among other things?
for example from Congo
now and guess
and the extraction of cobalt and copper
in the democratic republic of Congo
led to serious mensenrechtenschendingen
says amnesty international
child labor is the order of the day
but that's just the tip
residents are forced to leave their homes
to make room for mines
according to nsd this is sometimes accompanied by threats
deception and even sexual violence
climate colonialism is the new term
how am I supposed to become cynical and such an electric one
sell a car to myself
ah fuck it if wopke it can anyone can do it